[Music]
[Applause]
I'm in denial I don't want to face the
reality and my time at the GSB is coming
to an end
but that's what's happened that's the
harsh reality and I have to decide where
I'm going to go next
perhaps some you can relate I was going
to go back to Midwest that's where I'm
from originally I grew up in a farm in
Nebraska joy playing outside a
tight-knit community that supported me I
even got the exhibit pigs its County
Fair in the summer what a life
and later I moved to Minnesota for work
and I fell in love with the culture
people that are so polite kind and
reserved they even have a special term
for it's called Minnesota nice it's a
real thing but believe it or not the
Midwest actually hasn't been a popular
destination for GSB alums now I have
been working on my art skills and for an
illustration here I've created a crupac
of the United States and it looked back
and where last year's class ended up
right there you can see the distribution
we have a quite a few in Silicon Valley
in New York maybe even a few cowboys and
cowgirls in Texas but a huge hole in
between only about 2% we're going to the
Midwest but I kept hope maybe our class
would be different
so I sent a survey to my classmate 6-3
responded and of that 60 zero we're
going to Midwest after graduation common
reasons included things like too cold
the cultures too conservative there's
nothing to do from a social or
professional aspect and I don't have
ties to regions so why should I go I
started to reflect I mean was I missing
something here should I not be going to
less perhaps people are missing out on
an opportunity by not even considering
it so I decided to take a fresh look at
the region in terms of career
opportunities quality of life and
potential for societal impact first from
a career standpoint I know we all have
extremely high aspirations so I looked
at what past alums had done and what
they did to become the most successful
for instance Phil Knight didn't stay in
Silicon Valley
he went to beaver town Oregon to build
nike Mary Barra shoe to Detroit to work
for General Motors eventually becoming
CEO and fortunes most powerful woman in
business so perhaps there's a benefit to
going somewhere where everyone else
isn't prefer the returns researched I
spoke with Robert hata he's a partner at
Drive capital to VC firm focused on
funding Midwest startups is founded by
two former Sequoia partners who left
Silicon Valley for Columbus Ohio of all
places because the opportunities they
saw in the region part of that is it's a
very big economy you have a quarter of
the fortune 500 companies in the region
so for those GSB students who want to
work for a large company right away
there's ample opportunities and broad
industries that truly matter things like
health care financial services food and
agriculture for those who want to do
something made a little more exciting
there's even a budding startup scene one
of the benefits of being in the region
of the startup is you're close to many
of your consumers and competitors so
you're able to respond and learn from
them more quickly there's also a lot of
top state schools in the region so
you're able to draw from top talent and
computer science and engineering without
competing with companies like Facebook
and Google specifically as G C's we have
the opportunity to take some of the best
practices that we've learned at Stanford
in Silicon Valley and bring them to the
region to help grow it
things like rapid product development
and scaling building world-class teams
that because of current technology you
can do from anywhere so who knows maybe
we can even apply some of touchy-feely
skills and we'll build the first corn
unicorn in the region sounds great I
also spoke with David kid he lived in
Chicago Minneapolis and was my alumni
interviewer he worked in finance and
e-commerce and he pointed out that being
somewhere whether it's a relatively
smaller network is actually powerful
those who are in the region become
closer and you can leverage that network
more as an employee we become more
powerful to your employer because you
might do well if you can tap into the
broader Stanford network it's a good
situation to be in
so outside just the career aspects
though there is quality lifes consider
fast forward take five years you're
ready to settle down
married perhaps have a kid hopefully you
made your first million well maybe you
will buy a house with that but if you're
in San Francisco you know something like
that kind of fixer-upper instead say you
decide to go to Minneapolis you end up
with something like this
prime lakefront properties your choice
now it's not just the housing though
that's awesome weird Walt recently did a
study looking in terms of overall
quality of life from the aspects of
affordability Economic Opportunity and
work-life balance all five of the top
cities in its study were from the
Midwest places like st. Paul Minnesota
Lincoln Nebraska and Madison Wisconsin
there is a benefit to of going some
other slightly fewer people because it
makes activities more accessible to you
you'll get reservations through a
restaurant say it's easier same with
concert tickets and sporting events it's
a great time to be in the region as well
for sports I mean you have the World
Series champion Chicago Cubs
and it stolen of the NBA champion
Cleveland Cavaliers apologies to the
Golden State fans I realized little sad
your reign is over but it's okay I know
we also have a few foodies in the room
there's tons of farms in the area in
case you didn't know so you can eat
farm-fresh and local constantly and
trust me if you're carnivore like me
there's no better place in the world for
steaks I love it but it's not just about
the food the thing I miss most not being
in the region now is the people I had
the honor of having with my classmates
Michael visit he's a Nigerian over
winter break the thing that surprised
him most was how open and welcoming the
people were in the region something
Midwesterners pride themselves on you
know you say hi even wave to strangers
it's kind of strange at first we used to
it if you haven't visited I suggest you
do and you'll notice the difference now
in terms of societal impact collectively
I do think our decisions matter a
popular topic at the moment for instance
is the divide that's developed in our
country much that is geographic base the
coast in Middle America will call me
crazy but I don't think that's going
away anytime soon
if we just stay in Silicon Valley in New
York if you will see a change in the
region why not move there bring it if
you think people been left behind try to
bring the new economic opportunities I
realize there might be some resistance
being like these people are different
from me I don't know I don't know how to
connect but from my experience of living
in both regions there's more
similarities than differences it's also
enjoyable to hear a variety of side
that's how you truly learn to understand
one another and find common ground to
connect after talking through and
reflecting on my decision
I am confident I do want to go the
Midwest if you're still deciding and
what do will stand out your career
having sectional quality lies and helps
to unify our country enjoy me
[Applause]
[Music]